hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
chapter 14 of Aristotle's categories
focuses on one particular topic motion
or kinases in its broadest sense and
Aristotle analyzes it as you will do in
other places into six main types of
motion or change and this may be a
little bit foreign to some you know
modern a one more time in chapter 14 of
his categories Aristotle is examining
motion or change in Greek kinases the
word that we get kinetic from and he is
going to break it down into six main
types of motion and this will be a
little bit foreign I think to a modern
audience that often thinks of these
things in somewhat different ways and
he's just giving you sort of a thumbnail
sketch here not the sort of elaborate
treatment that he will say in the
metaphysics or in the physics but here
he is interested in distinguishing
between the different types in saying
how one type is not reducible to the
other types as some people in his own
time we're already saying and in
clarifying what the opposite of these
types of motion would be as well so
let's talk about the the basic types we
have generation in Greek Genesis right
destruction surah in in Greek so Genesis
or a generation is when something is
coming into being it is being brought
into existence destruction or corruption
sometimes it's translated is the
opposite course something is being
destroyed or consumed could be another
way of thinking about that so those are
two very important types of motion or
change and then we have two other ones
that are closely connected with each
other
Alex ASIS which means increase
or growth you know amplification is how
it's actually translated in the rhetoric
where Aristotle use of the same term and
did munition or shrinkage or however
else you want to put it may osis right
this is a another way of changing and
these are you know connected with each
other they don't just follow each other
in sequence here they're connected with
each other logically as well
so once you actually have something that
has come into being then it can increase
or decrease it can be destroyed likewise
something that is is in the process of
destruction might undergo growth at the
same time think about you know when
cancer is growing within a person the
cancer is growing the person is being
destroyed then we have another one which
in Greek is literally becoming other a
loyal sister ed olives is the Greek term
for other or different and we we're
translating this alteration or you might
also translate a change in quality or
you know we could might think of these
as change in quantity this is change in
quality going from being red to being
green going from healthy to being sick
and vice versa and then we have what we
typically think of when we hear the word
motion which is change in place contet
open meta Bolle contet open means in
relation to place right at opals is a
place and meta bola means means change
as well so we have all six types here
and Aristotle wants to say that these
are all fundamentally different from
each other we can distinguish these and
single them out as real you know ways in
which things do change he wants to
stress as well as I put here that
alteration is not something reducible to
the other five motions he says in the
case of alterations somebody might
object
that a subject when altered is altered
by one of the other five motions so that
for example going from one color to
another or changing health to sickness
or goodness to badness or anything like
that is really more a matter of changing
the arrangement of the parts right or
it's an increase or a decrease or its
generation of some sort something new
coming into being or something being
destroyed Aristotle says two really
interesting things here the first is he
says look it's not really the case that
alteration can be reduced to these other
things he says for by all or at least
most affections right pave or
alterations are brought about in us that
have nothing in common with what those
other motions we've mentioned view says
that which is thereby affected doesn't
have to be increased or diminished or
undergo any such process so it follows
from this that alteration is something
distinct from those other types of
motion and he says weren't the same with
some other object the object would alter
it would straight away also be increased
or diminished or undergo some other
motion but that is not so of necessity
so because we can in fact you know
distinguish changing in color from
changing in place or diminution or
destruction or whatever they're not the
same thing
they could be happen to the second point
they could be happening at the same time
he goes on to say that there are some
things that increase and are not thereby
altered you know you've got this example
of the square and maybe says there could
be some things that do increase at the
same time as they're being altered but
that doesn't mean that the increase and
the alteration are the same thing or the
change in place I mean there are some
interesting questions that we could put
there like well you know
Aristotle what if I if I put this book
in a dark room
my there by changing its color at least
how it appears to me right it's no
longer just this you know nice shade of
green but perhaps a darker shade of
green and Arizona let's say look to
begin with you're not actually changing
the color the book you're just changing
the circumstances under what you're
seeing it well let's say that it
actually did change the color of the
book you've got two things going on at
the same time alteration and change in
place and we could say the same thing
for for others as well now the other
thing that he talks about that's really
interesting here is rest and the Greek
word that he's using here is a remya
which can mean rest you know in like a
physical location it can also mean you
know it was the word we get hermit from
being being alone right
and he says rest is the contrary in
motion so that has to do with on the
high level right rest is the country of
motion but that doesn't mean that rest
is actually the contrary of every one of
these kinds of motion so what are the
contraries of those kings of motion he
says here we go change in place really
can be said to have rest in place for
its contrary so you know changing in
place staying in the same place those
seem to be contrary on the other hand
couldn't we say that for example I'm
Ching I'm going to change in place right
now I'm moving this way I've gone across
your screen wouldn't this going back to
where I was actually be the contrary not
just staying where I am but the reverse
of it so Aristotle says for example you
know ascent seems to be opposed to
descent and descent to accent and we can
say this about all the other ones as
well or we might even think about this
in terms of like turning
okay I'm turning this way that's a
motion exchange in place even though I
didn't actually change the place that
did change the arrangement of my body in
relation to the camera now maybe this is
the contrary to that this is one of
those cases where something may have
more than one contrary depending on how
we are looking at it when it comes he
says to these other four it's pretty
easy to tell what the contrary is
contrary to generation is destruction
and vice versa
these are canta knees types of motion
are contrary to each other
same thing with growth and diminution
they are contrary to each other I think
that doesn't even require all that much
explanation what about the one that we
haven't talked about here alteration
here Aristotle says this is this was not
that that easy we need to think about
this he says in fact it appears to have
no contrary or here to it is rest in a
certain way rest in its quality or
change to the contrary quality just as
we said change of place head for
contrary rest in a place or change to a
contrary place alteration says look
alteration means change of quality the
the becoming other means going from one
quality to its opposite so going or to a
different quality so presumably either
staying the same would be the opposite
of that the contrary to that or
reversing the process so going from
black to white right maybe staying black
is the contrary or maybe going from
white to black is the contrary if we're
thinking about moral terms like
Aristotle likes to use justice and
injustice remaining just would be the
contrary to changing from just to unjust
or going from unjust to just could also
be its contrary it depends on how
we want to look at it you might say well
this is not going to work because now we
have to contraries to to a single thing
but it really depends on the framework
so he says so black and white or
contrary is becoming the one will be
contrary to becoming the other there is
a change of quality here which implies
alteration and consequence into a
contrary quality we can say the same
thing about bitter and sweet or any of
the other eight tastes that Aristotle
distinguishes we could talk about all
sorts of other qualities that are
opposed to each other and the movement
from one into the other so this is a
really important chapter again it's a
thumbnail sketch this is not Aristotle's
full doctrine on that for that you want
to go to the physics and the metaphysics
but he does have it in the categories
here because he thinks these are things
that we want to get at least somewhat
clear about